welcome back to new rockstars the
internet went crazy with a big green
lady with muscles carrying her dates to
the bedroom and by the internet i mean
me but i also went crazy for the
realization of my life's long dream i i
can't even believe it frog man is in the
mcu kevin if you're watching i love you
i want to give you a hug what a true
blessing kevin feige has laid upon us
all this is rogue theory the show where
we pitch the wildest theories for the
nerdy titles that we love my name is mt
and going wrong with me today is someone
knocking down deranged saw walls
everywhere it's whitney van laningham
what's going on whitney everywhere i'm
doing this everywhere why are there
deranged soul walls everywhere in my
path i would like it if the walls near
me could be normal please
this sounds like unsafe working
conditions
okay sometimes like every uh every
building has a saw wall i don't know if
you knew this um it's for emergency
purposes every we just need an emergency
saw wall just in case people will get
every night has it's down everything has
its thorn every building has its saw
wall
exactly
every uh they have a
koala station and a saw wall in every
bathroom oh my god yes you have to
change your baby at the saw wall
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god and the legal counsel for all
the superhumans on twitch it's angelica
trey what's going on girl hi
it's good to be back and i'm very happy
to see some of your dreams coming true
mt with fragments this makes me
extremely happy i'm so excited for you
for this one i'm i'm in reality baby
thank you kevin that's amazing so good
and someone you wouldn't like to see
when he's angry my god is tommy bechdel
what's going on brother
oh i'm doing great great to be here
coming in last minute these theories are
going to be rogue they're going to be
fresh i'm glad my dreams aren't coming
true because last night i had a dream
two guys kidnapped me and fed my face to
me wow that happened in the multiverse
like you know that right what was that
like did they feed it to you for
breakfast for lunch or for dinner
because no they tied me up and there was
no meal they said now eat your nose and
they fed me pieces of my nose oh [ __ ]
yeah well did they say got your nose
before yeah
it was my greatest
this is your subconscious way of telling
you that you're just a snack
yeah oh
hey never mind and it turns out that was
a good dream yeah cause tommy you are a
snack everyone's looking like snacks
today you guys i said it before we came
on but like everyone is looking sexy
today and i honestly i think it's
it is in part because of she-hulk
because
the the big green mommy has like
awakened something in me and now i'm
barney as hell and i'm gonna be for the
rest of my life it's not gonna stop
it's not gonna stop i just want her to
pick me up like a little baby exactly i
just want a piggyback ride that's all i
want i haven't been
back right since i was like three that'd
be like i would love it
that would be so nice if i was out of
babies
would give
too she totally yeah like she's so chill
she wouldn't one
super chill like i can't wait for that
show it's gonna be great but yeah disney
plus just released a trailer for the
upcoming she-hulk series coming out in
august of this year and gave us our
first look at what the superhuman
attorney is going to be up to so that
leads us to our first topic of today
what would be the rogus cameo for
she-hulk because we know that jennifer
walters aka she-hulk will be taking up
the case for emil blonsky aka
abomination we haven't seen since 2008
when robbie downey jr was like hey uh
what's what's going on uh general guy
but it's just the hulk stuff's going on
at the post-credits scene
right
honestly
the most important thing for that movie
um anyway that's not true i love that
movie a lot but we also know that bruce
banner and wong will also appear on the
show but what would be one of the rogues
cameos we could see on this program like
maybe another client for jennifer or
another hero she meets along the way
like what do you think i mean mt what's
your answer now that frog man is
confirmed and real like what is your
answer now because your answer was
always give me frog man and now we got
brown man so who else even is there who
is even elsa exactly we have everyone in
the end we have everyone we need we
don't need to speculate anymore no more
characters
that's the only casting that will ever
matter ever again
yes oh my god people are not ready for
frogmate it's gonna freaking get
kick-ass it's gonna be amazing uh but
yeah what do you guys think is gonna be
like a super rogue cameo for shield i'll
tell you what i would love to see uh you
know doctor strange multiverse of
madness there were so many cameo rumors
unconfirmed like oh there was a version
where this person was gonna be in and we
shot scenes with this actor but i wonder
if all of those cameos maybe weren't
necessarily dr strange related but were
just adjacent to it or just marvel
cameos
i would love to see
uh
perhaps uh someone from that we have not
seen in an mcu project yet but we have
seen in previous
fox marvel projects i would love to see
uh
jennifer
take up the case of one magneto uh an
exonera in in his quest for like maybe
exoneration since like the his crimes
were last uh
what was like the 90s when uh dark
phoenix came out or was supposed to take
place in right so maybe it's been 30
years
yeah no no not not when it came out but
when it took place it took place in the
night
i was thinking the wrong phoenix movie
i'm sorry yeah
no but uh i mean i think that movie came
out in like 2017 but i think but i i
would love for maybe her to take the
case of magneto i see maybe he's seeking
uh a full pardon or whatever maybe he's
you know
who knows what magneto's up to but i i i
would love to have him appear that would
just be magnet
yeah
hashtag magnet
i'm going to say that the first time we
see magneto in the trailer like oh my
god magnet that's so magnet
i mean even needle works in there too
exactly
oh my god if i was best friends with
magneto i'd be like hey nina what's
going on
i maintained that the most that was the
most unrealistic part of x-men uh first
class was that they told him they named
him magneto and he was like
all right
i'm like there's no way michael michael
fassbender would have been like get the
goddamn no way
something way cooler than that
call me something cooler than eric
magneto like
it's the nerdiest name i'm sorry
i know i've said this to you people
before i've said it to people in my life
i just think that eric magneto is the
dweebiest name and i know that that's
not his like
christian name but it's the name that i
refer to him in my mind and no his
mother was like my beautiful baby my
beautiful baby eric magneto
but no so no tommy so do you think that
magneto is already in like earth 616
with his powers yeah that's my theory
my theory is that there's a there's a
version of of magneto that maybe isn't
as diabolical as the magneto from the
fox
universe i i think they'll probably
ultimately establish that as a different
universe which makes sense
but there is
a magneto and maybe he has done some
not so magneto things uh or about
magneto things that aren't so neat
i guess as as as our language
things am i right
that's a wrap that's an amazing rap name
yeah it's me magnasty lifting up the
school bus lifting up the
san francisco bridge going to get bridge
i don't know
[Laughter]
oh but no um
i think a really fun idea for that would
be like you know we know in was it first
class or one of those uh fox x-men
movies where like he goes on a tear
killing all of these nazi
um people so like what if he's killing
nazis in america and like he gets
arrested and he's like no i was doing a
good thing uh it's i'm doing a surface
for our community killing nazis and
jennifer walters like what
i like i like that your magneto is kind
of serious
voice that's not michael like oh yes i
was doing a good thing i was mad i was
doing a good thing i'm becoming more
mature yeah
i don't know what's going on here speech
i'm not gonna lie that's my magneto too
that's what i think of i know me too i i
think of serene mckellen too for sure
sure but they're both great but i do
think of mckellen more for maggie yes
you know that's our generation that's we
grew up about that mckellen um but no i
love that idea it's a really fun idea
it's super rogue what do you ladies
think so
i'm trying my best not to make a shrek
joke in here
um like i want like a green universe
exactly tell me angelica i want a green
universe i want all the like green
kind of like giant or you know like tall
taller people to get you know involved i
want like the jolly green giant want
shrek in there
absolutely
exactly if we had some sort of
multiverse thing go down i would hope
there would be like a giant just green
multiverse somewhere oh yeah
some greenness
[Laughter]
purchased with that martha stewart money
that he earned
exactly but which name does he have is
it snoop doggy dog is it snoop lion or
is he just going straight snoop dogg
here i think he's going straight snoop
dogg because it's the green multiverse
you know okay yeah yeah yeah true
classic
so um i
i would obviously love to see like you
know just when you mentioned that my
brain went to all the lawyers i would
love to see you know jerry hogarth and
and characters like that but we're going
rogue right now so
what if there was a situation where
frogman maybe got into some
i don't know just
just it got into some trouble was
hopping around town
and
you know got detained got arrested and
now frog man
he would riot
would break him out of jail like
this movie doesn't need to exist if mt
finds out that frogman is in trouble
he's going there's no there's no tv show
there's no man breaking out frogman i
don't know why i imagine you doing that
like a looney tune you know with like a
big was it the acme bomb
right
[Laughter]
like it's the wild west you're just
busting them out yeah
he's hopping
yeah
so so frogman got into some trouble
frogman needs representation
and
who better to represent frogman than
saul goodman that's right
breaking bad is in the same universe as
the mcu so that was headed upstate they
better call when it comes to frogs
it's just that that no heroes care about
any crime that's happening in new mexico
so anyways
a lawyer line up
that is incredible i would look
incredible i'd love to see the crossover
with the multiverse anything could
happen that's what the mobile video is
saying
and also here's what i'm thinking i feel
like this actually a crossover between
better call saul maybe could happen
because like isn't that a disney
property with f is not on fx right um is
is saul good morning it is not it's an
amc
oh
[ __ ]
well anyway okay here's the point even
though better better call salt probably
couldn't be on in this multiverse i feel
like a lot of other disney owned
properties can be because think about
this because like we have um star wars
references in in
marvel already and we know that dreams
are the gateway to the multiverse so as
long as one person has a dream about
star wars than any other like disney or
anything like technically the dc
universe can be in marvel because
someone said superman so like i feel
like saul goodman if marvel studios were
to make a deal with with amc it's
possible if someone has a dream about
solve for them to come to the mcu and be
like oh hey i could represent somebody
it's totally fine
i think it's possible i don't think it's
super out of the ordinary or super i can
represent somebody and then shrek shows
up
full circle okay
but but
for real though i would also love to see
you know anything like jessica jones but
i know that's crossing the entire
country right that's like the
i don't care west coast that's my answer
oh sorry don't worry
later
don't worry i'll go i'll explain it
anyways
continue continue
okay yeah
i just love jessica jones i want to see
jessica somehow
cross east coast to west coast i'm just
throwing out every theory ever there but
um also you know jerry hogarth somehow
some way i would love to see that just
like the lawyers of the mcu just all
congregate
somehow in she-hulk
oh my i would love to see hogarth and
like obviously matt murdock and like all
the lawyers just come together just for
like a the lawyer avengers
foggy
foggy nelson coming on oh my god
but yeah i think that it's highly likely
that we might see one of these netflix
um characters crossing over into
she-hulk because you know obviously we
have um
daredevil popping up and no way home and
like echo um sorry not echo
kingpin coming up in uh in hawkeye so
like it's just i feel like it's
inevitable for us to see some type of
lawyery type cameo with this show and
like i feel like hogarth is the best but
um no i think it'd be really dope to see
uh one of those lawyers pop up for sure
but like yeah i think that uh we all
know what whitney's guess is here yeah
okay but now sorry but don't worry don't
be sorry i'm just gonna link it up for
you all right so we're saying that
better call stall exists right so then
that means that breaking bad exists and
who was in breaking bad uh jessica jones
so what's up no methamphetamine not even
cocaine cocaine would have been classier
breaking bad that classic show about
cocaine that classic cocaine
[Laughter]
no it's perfect it's all good no but she
so she's in that's how she could be in
that world but in all seriousness i
think that it could be something because
like angelica just said i do think that
it is a good idea to
keep like introducing little little
defender cameos and stuff because we do
have kingpin like mt said we have uh
matt murdock in no way home there's
rumors that matt murdock might be an
echo i think i've heard that somewhere
around the internet i've heard that dude
that i think i've heard that somewhere
maybe in like you're making it up with
me i'm inventing things doing rumors
i think i've heard that somewhere so i
think that it would be really cool and
interesting if the way that they
introduced jessica jones into she-hulk
is if
jessica is like me okay she's a little
bit of a drinker she gets a little
loosey-goosey after a couple after
t-mini martinis uh and so i think that
jessica could get herself into some kind
of hot water some maybe some drunken
shenanigans maybe she just beat up the
wrong guy maybe she you know
whatever jessica does and i think that
matt murdock could be representing her
and is like hey
this is my friend she-hulk she-hulk
you're taking over jessica now because i
don't i don't have room on my client
roster for her so i'm trading her off to
you and then maybe jessica gets sent to
that little the little prison that's out
there because you know how she hulk is
gonna be the lawyer for the prison where
all the super people go or whatever so
maybe jessica gets sent there and as a
favor to matt murdock
she-hulk takes the case
that's what i think it's gonna be
i love this a lot i see it and like i
also love this idea of matt burdock
being like oh i've got to give jessica
jones to uh it's a she-hulk because
she's a superhuman person and i have no
superpowers i have no superpowers i
can't take this case i'm just a normal
time man everyone guys
[Laughter]
yeah i was trying i was going like this
oh okay okay i see it now i see it
i don't look for it
i was mostly just swishing my face and
it's me too
mostly when i talk to women i'm like
it's like it's really freaking out um
eddie i don't know what i'm saying
anyway continue oh wait no i know i love
this idea of um jessica jones popping up
and cause like i've wanted this for a
long time like for her to pop up in
she-hulk specifically because i love two
strong women together teaming up i need
them to team up actually step on me
mommies i need two mummies to step on me
on me mommy's i know i want jessica
jones on she hulk's shoulders and then
and then they step back
for the full weight of both of them
stepping on me just like one of them
crushing your head with their thighs the
other one crushing your torso with their
thighs just a full snug a full body snug
of a lawyer and a lady
i'm in it exactly i'm into it a lawyer
and a detective lady that's what i meant
to say i
i'm not gonna lie i kind of like the
idea too of
she-hulk right of jennifer going on her
dates that were featured in the trailer
and then jessica
crashing them somehow oh that'd be fun
and ruining them i like that
also i just kind of like the idea of
like
jessica and jennifer out on the table
yeah they're having a good time and they
won't frown because they're like
just like i just want to see
i love the dynamics of like all the the
female heroes in the comics like a lot
like some of them just like hang out
like uh i love jessica jones and captain
marvel and
jessica drew's dynamic a lot like i want
to see three of them hanging out but
also she-hulk she looks
literally hanging out with everybody
because she's a lawyer like hanging out
with like random people so like yeah i
feel like um jessica jones and in
she-hulk hey first of all i ship that
couple 100 oh i ship it 2 000
please give it to me but
but also i just i just think it's just a
natural fit for you know for for jj to
come up and she'll just i just feel like
it's it makes sense considering that
there really isn't a
i feel like a marvel likes to introduce
characters that were in other shows like
yeah dramatic setting so like we have um
what's it called the kingpin showing up
in the more ground yeah in hawkeye and
now and daredevil's probably going to
show up in echo and so like since this
show is going to be about like super
powered people super powered uh women
like sort of like the legacy of the the
super soldier project i sort of feel
like jessica jones is a perfect fit for
uh something like that so mcu phase 4 is
so horny and like jessica jones is horny
like she's always trying you know like
like the phase four is so horny and i
want all right i'm here for it i want
all of it
but yes i love that theory a lot so i'm
gonna give you
fifteen thousand rogue points for that
one my friend um but this ma the theory
of magneto magneto the man himself the
neato magneto um showing up that would
be
the
most jaw-dropping thing of all time if
that happened on the show i don't like
it would be like what the heck
um like i'm but like i
i also gotta give you 15 000 for that
one honestly because like that is just
too it's too it's too good it's too good
it's too good and also uh we have these
uh other lawyers jerry hogarth like
saul goodman for crying
my brain just loves to like just cross
and just can like combine universes and
so i always have to remember i'm like oh
i should keep it within the universe but
also how epic would that be no way
that's why your brain is sexy baby
that's why i'm the first to make like a
shrek joke
yeah that's true
but no
i would love to see
these different types of lawyers even
saw goodman appear on the show it would
just be really fun um just to like see
more because like the mcu is definitely
leaning more towards the grounder level
types of people and like you know just
more about the people of the mcu sort of
why we're seeing frogman in the show in
the first place is because he's a man of
the people he fights for the people
we're seeing like the people people so
yeah i want to see some lawyers hardcore
so i'm also going to give you 15 000
points for that because
all the lawyers
all the lawyers and lawyers and i'm
assuming that you're also including the
lawyers from the law and order sv
universe as well because we have already
talked about that
and the special country unit oh my god
we have so many we have so many lawyers
you guys
my god lawyer team up let's go all your
team up let's go let's go
oh but yes this could be anyone's game
even though the points don't really
matter we're just having fun up next
we're really talking about
they matter hardcore um seriously your
taxes they matter i'm here to win it
but yes up next we are going to talk
about the godly faces of thor love and
thunder but first a great way to support
the channel is to check out all of our
awesome merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com not.org or dot gov
i know a lot of you get tripped up with
that don't do that um there's a lot of
there's a great lineup of merch inspired
by doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness including our limited edition
latest obsession shirt shattered madness
and once it's gone it's gone for good so
be sure to grab one for your multiverse
as soon as you can check out all of our
great themed merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com.gov or uh dot org
or or i don't know dot gov is for narcs
don't go there seriously yeah
seriously.gov is only for narcs new
rockstarsmerch.com or die
that's our newest last obsession shirt
do rockstar switch.com or die uh we're
really leading into capitalism here uh
just
oh
it can be hard to see the light at the
end of the tunnel when you have high
interest debt and sometimes it can be
even harder to ask for help but that's
where upstart comes in upstart powered
personal loans can help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple easy to understand payment terms
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom so whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
upstart can help you get one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff date
upstart knows that you're more than just
your credit score upstarts model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 to get this
50 000
you don't have to rob a bank they'll
just give it to you if you qualify
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
literally a day after you have fifty
thousand dollars what the heck
that's amazing so don't wait and check
your rate today at upstart.com rogue
theory that's upstart.com rogue theory
to check your rate today and don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application so go to
upstart.com
rogue theory we also want to thank
bespoke post for sponsoring this video
take your summer adventures to the next
level with bespoke posts and their new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections bespoke post
partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you the most
unique goods every month no matter what
you have going on this season box of
awesome has you covered from camping
gear essentials to beach day and travel
must-haves box of awesome has everything
you need for summer i'm really excited
for their scorch box which features hot
sauces from small brands from places
like california texas nevada and more
i'm going to make every cookout this
summer a spicy one because my gi system
um just hates me anyway so why not um
heartburn for everyone take the quiz at
box of awesome.com to find the right box
for you there are new boxes every month
and each box is valued at around 70 but
you only pay a fraction of the price
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com and enter the code
rogue at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code rogue for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com
code
code
rogue r-o-g-u-e
all right gang so we also got a new
image from for love and thunder which is
set to hit theaters on july 8th four
days after independence day we get
another independence day with um jade
foster liberating our hearts um with
with love and thunder so with its
release being around the corner it's got
us thinking what other gods might appear
in for love and thunder because with
this new promo image from the four
sequel showing king valkyrie jane frost
thor and what appears to be the goddess
best finally seeing the best in the mcu
what other gods from marvel comics might
make an appearance in this film i don't
care i just want jesus to make a cave i
wanted jesus i just want jesus christ
the mcu jesus christ to show up finally
like that's all i [ __ ] want
like finally like you've been waiting
for this moment
[Laughter]
ever since iron man 1 when tony got
blown up i was waiting for jesus christ
to show up in sandals to be like hello
my son um i'll save you from this from
these shrapnels just kidding or like
that's not true have you guys seen the
cross
like that mural of jesus christ putting
his hand on thanos's head as thanos
kneels and is like i'm sorry and jesus
is like i'm stronger and bigger than you
like that's what i want to see
i just want jesus to save us
oh my god
that's kind of that would be hilarious i
i i i tweeted a couple of days ago that
i wanted i want to see jesus like first
of all a brown jesus yes like in sandals
just fighting for the god butcher 100.
just being an unnecessarily badass fight
for no i think there should be a team of
jesus's there should be like real actual
accurate jesus there should be
republican whites
oh my god that would be an incredible
comic like an indie comic jesus but it
stands for something like
judicious
uh
extraction squad
it's an acronym i love that jesus
assembled
jesus is simple
oh my god one of them is just jim
kavisol the actor who played jesus and
passionately one of them
and is like why am i here guys i don't
have any powers my name is just jim
caviezel i was also in the count of
monte cristo but nobody ever talks about
that like you're the man of the chair
keviezel you're the man in the chair
okay so that's right that's my final
answer jesus christ in the emcee
so badly because it would just be like
you know obviously with all these gods i
mean marvel studios is really great so
they're very respectful with all the
gods so like as long as they handle it
respectfully let's see jesus fight gore
the god butcher i want to see it it'd be
really dumb i want to see it yeah i want
to know how he stands out i'm sorry how
could that possibly be handled
respectfully i don't think you could i'm
not going
guys to going to have jesus christ fight
going to god
but don't worry but don't worry
we're seriously it's gonna be a
taste so many meetings
yeah so many meetings just to discuss
this but they they gotta get him in
there somehow you know he's a fan
favorite
people been asking members of america
would let me live if i ever did that and
then we can find out like is thor
stronger than jesus because if thor can
save him well she's stronger than jesus
the question everyone wanted i want to
see that
who's deciding that is that like
he's decision
like i want him to play that would be
amazing okay sorry enough of this i'm
sorry i'm sorry i apologize
even though we know it's the right
answer to this question everyone else
yes i would love to see that um big time
please tell me your answers i'm sorry
guys
so
no all good all good um
so i
this might be fresh on my mind here but
thor love and thunder we have
gore the god butcher
wreaking havoc right so the gods i'll
call a council to discuss how to proceed
right
and uh none other than mark spector
shows up
talking in all caps
because
his he's the avatar for khan shu
and uh kanchu is just spouting all the
different ways to just brutally kill
gore
that's what i think having fun i'd like
that can i crush the moon
yeah and they're all just sitting there
stoically like that's actually the
screenshot that we saw right
they're all sitting there stoically just
watching mark just talking in all caps
how do we handle this guy
hardcore like we do like
we have heard that there were talks to
incorporate uh gord the god butcher
within the story of moon knight so like
it would really be great if to see
oscar isaac appear in an actual big
screen mcu film as the the as the avatar
for country and be like hello
strong women i'm glad that you're up
there i love seeing women in power also
would you like me to move the moon on to
gor the god butcher
we're going to throw the moon on a gore
why is this coming through gorgeous
aren't you working so hard to appear
feminist in this strong women i am
actually present consciousness i'm so
blessed
i know this has nothing to do with my
character earlier but i have suddenly
developed a great appreciation for women
no look it's con she now kind of she's
exactly it's con say it right
she was like secretly in love with layla
is layla's biggest fan so like when she
became the scarlet scarab he's like i
love powerful women now i love powerful
women
we have to go to the west coast mark for
for no reason at all for no reason at
all
but uh no i i love that a lot i think
it'd be really dope to see mark spector
for sure yeah moon knight crossover
let's let's get him in there i'm into
that i think that all the gods you know
applaud kanchu for defeating ahmet
honestly because uh that could have been
a problem
it could have been a real big probity
yeah
what do you think that tommy i mine is
not as exciting but i think it would
herald i doubt it
yeah yourself sure no no no i'm not i
think that's a good answer guys i think
it's a strong answer i just don't know
that it's a you know an exciting answer
i believe they're going to use this
opportunity to introduce both the silver
surfer and his master galactus and now
galactus may not technically be a
god but he is a celestial being and he
is you know vaguely defined as god-like
in that world and i wonder if maybe he
wants a seat at the table and he's like
you guys
can't stop gore by yourselves you need
me
you need galactus or at least my herald
silver surfer you know what i i think
that the that would be exciting
like no i think that first of all i
think that would be really exciting and
really cool yeah um and i also think
that the mcu definition of a god is like
a huge like a
cosmic being that is either a force of
creation or destruction
i think that
he would 100
fall into that category of a god right
so
and i think i don't think that any the
gods of the mcu universe have any other
choice than to hear this dude out so
like you know if he wants to sit at the
table he's going to have to stay at the
table i mean it might even not he may
not even appear it might just be silver
surfer appearing to like you know right
announce his i would love i need to see
her hardcore like for some reason this
is going to sound weird but like i think
that michael borzenbaum would make a
great silver surfer even though he is
already in the mcu as um that crystal
man um in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
i think it'd be great if uh him and also
his best friend stakar stallone just
become variants of uh galactus with
stallone as galactus and uh
that man michael rosenbaum is still
reserved would be really great if they
were just like all right guys sorry this
is weird but no galactus
amazing fit i think it it fits for the
marvel cinematic universe and i think
that's pretty damn rogue to me so i'm
going to give you 30 000 points for that
brother
hell yeah hello
hell yeah um but i love it um but i do
love these other um gods as well um what
did you say angelica it was really good
um can't you
mark spectre's shouting
[Laughter]
i only use 20 000 points for that one
angelica because konchu of course the
moon god himself he's like
one of the first gods that we've seen
outside of the asgardian pantheon so
like he's got to appear
during this huge god conflict and i do
want to see oscar isaac because he's
just a handsome man in general and like
every just he's got to see oscar isaac
from time to time i just want to see him
screaming with all the stoic woman i
just want to see
him
just being that
very neurotic type character i just i
don't know i think it would be a really
fun juxtaposition
yes i also want to see jake lockley um
just talking to the whole council
the whole council would be dead
like instantly
but yes uh but whitney of course was the
jesus christ the jesus christ himself
coming to thor love and thunder i would
love to see it um and obviously it would
be really tough to do it respectfully
and i'd be no disrespect because i
obviously i'm not obviously i grew up in
a christian household so i know a lot
about jesus
necessarily um so yes
25 000 points to whitley for jesus
christ
listen i'm going to donate every penny
of that to the church
yes
i believe they cast jesus in the mcu i
will donate all of my rogue points to
the church
for letting us borrow jesus for our this
movie should be great
who has the cinematic rights to jesus
let us know in the comment section below
let us know in the comment section below
do you have the right the cinematic
rights to jesus
sorry um
here we go
uh they bought jesus in the sony
spider-man deal i don't know how it
happened but they did jesus's agent is
at caa
oh my god wow
that's pretty good i know it would suck
if jesus's agent was like at icm
partners but like no don't worry jesus
is at caa
good he's in good hands there i bet oh
yeah for sure
good god all right now this brings us to
our rogue question are you guys ready
for it yes yeah yes because
a woman by the name of kathleen kennedy
talked about the future of star wars
films this week have you heard of star
wars it's pretty good it's about space
people thanks pretty neat and stated
that they want to move away from the
skywalker saga so i mean i'm not really
sure how much i really believe that
because that's that's the moneymaker i
don't know if they're gonna get away i
don't know but anyway pitch me your
rogus idea for a star wars film that has
nothing to do with the previous nine
films in the skywalker saga because i
personally think that they need to move
away from that and just start new things
what about like a show about just jawas
yeah just the little guys just jawless
it's called
it's just no talking just javascript
what if you do the show or whatever what
about that little you know that japanese
show about three-year-olds running
errands for the first time what if yeah
what if it's little three-year-old jawas
making their first trades
yeah
jawa's running errands
doing their first sand trade mm-hmm
and then my show is going to be about
baby tuscan raiders
and then and then there's going to be a
crossover special with the baby jaw was
and the baby doesn't matter
it's going to be like muppet babies but
way more violent than muppet babies
oh my
yes
my my show begins on a far away unnamed
planet as a
uh rebellion officer
knocks on the door
a woman
answers
yes
and it's the worst news she's ever
always hoped would never come but
deep inside her heart knew one day she'd
get
ma'am
i'm sorry to tell you your husband
porkins was killed
out from behind her a chubby little boy
walks away walks out from under her
little cloak and goes papa
pop is gone
yes son
gone you're the man of this house now
you're the man of this house now
and then
little tiny perkins jr looks into their
mirror and goes
i'm gonna kill luke skywalker
and it's the story of revenge
it's the story of one boy's
lifetime of revenge or avengeing of his
father
struck down in his prime during the
trench run that destroyed the first
death star wow you know what
i would love to see it honestly like the
story of a revenge story with perkins
just hating luke skywalker
i don't know how he knows that luke
skywalker is even at all to blame
because
it's not like there's like
intergalactic news or anything like that
but maybe he just hates the rebel or
maybe he blames the empire maybe he's a
good guy maybe he breaks good maybe he
goes i mean i would love i'm gonna kill
the emperor i would love for there to be
an entire series with this mysterious
villain and then it's like you remove
this map it's me pawkins jr remember me
and they were like no luke skywalker's
like who who
i don't know who you are
i love this idea so much it's so
hilarious um
that was good are you going with the
tuscan raiders like from real men
yeah
okay why not i don't care yeah i wanna i
wanna go all in with angelica and i
wanna do baby tuscan raiders and baby
jawas and then
you're the showrunner of jawas
we come together
let's go let's send it off
get this green let's get this going
obviously and then perkins is the star
because perkins comes and he solves the
problems between the joa and justin
raider nation and they declared him
there they declared him their girl oh
god god baby porkins
and he goes to thor love and thunder and
he gets to be on the council
exactly
with jesus
it's all connected synergy all four of
us together if we combine
[Laughter]
universe
[Laughter]
[Music]
but uh no i think that this is that's an
amazing idea to see the jawas and the
tuscan raiders just just battle it out
and then maybe become mates and maybe
join their little communities together
um so i'm gonna give both of you uh just
50 000 points for that one but i've got
to give tommy
two million rogue points yes he deserves
it yeah he deserves it for perkins
i agree
a revenge story do we have johnny it one
day do we even need to tally the points
up guys i think
i think maybe tommy
i don't know it's it's cutting it close
you know i think i can't
i think i got kind of close there for a
minute so let's add them all up guys and
get out with my like 2 000. let's do
this the right way
[Music]
[Applause]
what a great group there are no
excuse me losers amongst us except for
me who's choking on his own saliva right
now
i think that if tommy wins rogue theory
it means that he wins she-hulk scooping
him up like a little baby
and carrying him all the way home i
think that's his cries put tommy's face
on that man right now
if i knew that was on the line i would
have painted myself green today
come on
a little bit of a heads up guys
but
yes our winner for today and that is it
for our this is crazy episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our amazing
guests whitney van laningham angelica
trey and of course tommy beck told for
joining us today follow them wherever
they are on social media and just
support them whatever they do they're
amazing people and you can support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
at mastertainment to see me tweet some
weird [ __ ] and insane theories yes we
love you so much thank you guys so much
for watching and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
foreign